[Music]
good evening everyone thank you first of
all to Vijay for having me back I was
with a group of developers who worked on
a react open-source project having to do
with server-side rendering and we had a
lot of fun I'm speaking together it was
five of us passing off the speaking
roles back and forth for the course of
the meetup so this time I'm holding down
the fort alone but I'm excited I'm very
excited to have a chance to nerd out
with you guys for a little bit about
JavaScript modules and this is a top
that of topic that I think is
particularly fascinating because when we
look at the history and the development
of modules in JavaScript we're kind of
going in parallel with we're tracing the
history of JavaScript growing as a
language from kind of humble origins as
this lightweight scripting language that
was running in Netscape to really
becoming a powerhouse that gives us the
modern web with all of its interactivity
and everything that we love about it so
now we're basically in an era where we
have JavaScript running everywhere
Universal JavaScript JavaScript on the
client and on the server side on we have
it in our thermostats even flying Jones
for us so needless to say javascript has
come a very long way and so have modules
oh and the pronunciation of my name for
anyone who might have been wondering is
meetin rhymes with region so just anyway
so the first thing that I would like to
posit is that modules are a fundamental
part of our lives as JavaScript
developers they're kind of part of the
scenery so I do a lot of my day-to-day
work in a react codebase so when I fire
up my code editor many of the files I'm
looking at have kind of a predictable
structure I see some import statements
at the tops and export statements at the
bottom I almost don't even think about
them I mean
unless I've put a typo in my file path
or something and I than I am thinking
about them but I imagine there are other
folks in the room working in other
frameworks and working in other modular
type code bases and environments so
modules and modular thinking are kind of
second nature to us and that's really
how it should be modules are supposed to
make our lives easier as developers they
do this by giving our code structure and
boundaries so that way we don't have to
think about all of the moving parts I
don't have to have the react source code
mingling with my component logic I can
take a grant I take for granted that
it's going to be available for me and do
what I wanted to do most the time so for
now it resides elsewhere out of sight
and out of mind and this is especially
important as code bases get bigger so
when we hear about terms like modularity
and separating concerns that's really
about our sanity as developers who are
working with each other and working with
a lot of code so let's start out and get
on the same page as far as our concepts
and terminology and we'll start with the
basics what's a module anyway I like to
think about modules as building blocks
of data and functionality and we can
bring them into a program and we can
also make them available to other
programs and ideally you can kind of
treat them like you would build building
blocks and hopefully you can add or
remove pieces from the whole without the
whole structural integrity falling apart
so when we're talking about modules
we're really talking about the
higher-level design of our software
we're often thinking about modules in
terms of a single file because that's
typically how we organize our modules
one module one file we can also talk
about modules in terms of their
relationships to other modules so a
module has an interface and that's it's
exposed bits that let us have data and
if I
available for use in other programs I
kind of like to think of the module
interface as the little bumps on the top
of Lego brick so you can try to put your
Lego bricks side-by-side and they won't
really stick together but and those
little bumps which I actually just found
out are called studs Lego studs or how
we actually get our structures to stick
together and so module interfaces are a
little bit like that and a module can
also have dependencies and and often
that just means that we're dealing with
other functionality that we're relying
on to have the functionality of whatever
module we're working in and so just a
hammer a hammer at home in case there's
any ambiguity about my personal
physician on this modules are awesome
they help us to keep organized code
bases especially as those code bases are
growing in complexity they help us
resolve our dependencies making sure
that any pieces of code are supposed to
be there and we don't have to worry
about getting them all in the right
order they also help us to share and
reuse code so we have a wonderful thing
called NPM that gives us access to
literally I think 700,000 packages right
now a lot of packages of code and we
ourselves can be part of a community
contributing to that global repository
alongside others so kind of cool but
before we go any further if there is an
elephant in the room and we should
acknowledge it
so these modules which I've been talking
about and that are so fundamental to
modular to modular and modern
programming are actually just barely a
part of JavaScript they weren't built
into JavaScript pre es6 so for most of
its years as a language javascript
didn't have any kind of built in native
module system so this is unlike Python
for example and so modules only really
recently became part of the language and
they've actually only just landed
modern browsers like as of this year so
oftentimes when we're working with
modules we're not working with the built
in module system at all we might be
using require statements if we're
working a node or comma J yes we might
be using import statements like I showed
earlier from react code we might be
using Favell to transpile them down to
es5 and then to bundle those files that
were all supposed to be separate into a
single one for consumption by the
browser so what's going on well this is
where I started getting curious like
what how did we work for so long without
modules and JavaScript and as I started
to take a peek into the history I found
that there was this overarching
storyline that JavaScript was really
built disadvantaged when it came to
modules it wasn't built with any kind of
modularity in mind when it was first
invented it was just supposed to be
lightweight scripting inline scripting
and over time as more demands were made
of JavaScript as a language to do more
for us we see an increasing need so
running in parallel for usable module
systems so I like to think of the
history of JavaScript as unfolding in
four phases
I made these up so I call it the pre
module era the do-it-yourself module
phase the specification phase and the
standardization phase and because it is
something I made up and because it is a
system of chronology it is not perfect
not precise but what I was aiming to do
and kind of splitting our timeline into
these four segments was to bring some
order to overall trends that we were
that we're taking place so I'll do a
little flyover right now before we jump
in and get into more detail for each of
those phases but let's start at the
beginning in the pre module era when
modules were not really a thing at all
Java scripts didn't itself have much of
an identity or much
respect let's be honest at that point it
was nothing like it is today
and that didn't last too long before we
started realizing that we needed some
kind of modules but in the absence of
those built-in modules we were
improvising we were making module type
structures ourselves so roughly in 2011
we start to see module specifications
growing in popularity the JavaScript
community especially the service
server-side JavaScript community was
really starting to take off and a lot of
work had to be done just to make
JavaScript the language people wanted to
develop in and a big part of that was
just coming on to the same page so
that's also kind of our era of single
page apps and frameworks like backbone
and angular starting to come into vogue
and finally today we have arrived in the
era of standardization and that's the
phase that is currently underway and I
hate to spoil the plot right at the
beginning but javascript is still pretty
far from having a standardized module
system we do have a standard system in
place but we're still working out the
kinks and we're still making things hold
together in the ways that we hope that
they will so that one day we will all be
gloriously developing with modules and
not having to think about all the quirks
that go with with trying to do that all
right so let's begin our tour we begin
in a time before modules Java scripts
age of innocence and as we peek into the
yearbook
don't-don't-don't we come across gems
like this so totally 90s and I'm calling
this the Dark Age that really I think we
were probably having a good time anyone
had a geocities website I sure did
I think it was called like the raspberry
garden or something it's like 12 anyway
it had all these cool neighborhoods like
Soho and Sunset Strip and Times Square
and I guess you can go to the wayback
machine if you want to have some
nostalgia but anyway as I'm looking at
this specimen from the archives I think
I'm seeing at least for sure one
definite use of inline scripting which
is probably like this fun little
animated status bar that's going it's
crossing the screen for your
entertainment any one spot any others
that's the only one but I feel like kind
of confident on what a time what a time
but anyway yes a Wild West of inline
scripting and script tags no modules to
speak of really a question I want us to
start thinking about is is this scalable
what are some of the problems we
encounter in this Wild West scenario
well I'll say more about that in a
moment but first let's get one thing
straight at this stage in the game no
one was really think about thinking
about scalability that was not the name
of the game and if you don't take it
from me take it from the inventor of
JavaScript himself mr. Brendan Eich I
hope he pronounces it that way too
I could I could be bettering it but he
did say in an interview with InfoWorld
that no one thought JavaScript would be
used at the wild wide scale that it is
not just reaching lots of people on the
web but large applications like Gmail to
write large code you don't just want
this little snippet language that I made
for beginners beginners you want strong
api's and ways of saying hey this is my
module and this is your module and you
can throw your code over to me and I can
use it safely so quick trivia question
the
anyone know what your JavaScript was
invented yeah 95 or did you say 95 that
is exactly right over the course of 10
very intense days for mr. Ike and I
think it's an original instructions from
Netscape we're actually to have a
language that was a lot more like scheme
for the browser so if anyone's worked
with scheme which is kind of a dialect
of Lisp you know it looks completely
different from the JavaScript we know
and love those instructions those
marching orders changed significantly
and I feel grateful for that so in the
in 2006 we get the first of several
manifestos that we will see so this
particular manifesto came from the Yahoo
user interface team in a blog post with
the title global domination and they had
a good point I would say and the point
that they were trying to make is that
global variables are a terrible risky
practice that we're all engaging in this
unsafe behavior that we're all engaging
in but in growing code bases we really
had to cut cut cut that out and so
what's the problem
well global variables are notoriously
unreliable and insecure and there are a
few reasons for that and the first has
to do with variable naming collisions
so assuming Mary and George the you why
on the Yui dev team are working on the
same code a name to the very their
variable the same thing they were likely
to run into trouble pollution in the
global namespace and globally scoped
variables aren't just well they're just
really easy to break or to forget that
they even exist and sick secondly
because they're exposed they're not
secure so it's not just coworkers who
might innocently bump into each other in
the global namespace dance floor
third-party scripts and malicious code
join in the fun and global variables are
a vulnerability that we generally want
to avoid especially if we're Yahoo and
were the big guns in the game in the
mid-2000s so the Yui team actually went
as far as to say that an objective
measure of the quality of a JavaScript
program is how many global variables and
global functions does it have a large
number is bad because the chance of bad
interactions with other programs goes up
and a few other issues we're cropping up
in this era in this pre module era
whenever you wanted to reuse code you'd
likely be doing some kind of copy/paste
job and then following the trail of
breadcrumbs wherever it led you and any
time you tried to update your code it
would likely be a logistical nightmare
as you tried to find all the pieces the
places where you needed to update it
this dependencies were a hassle to
manage especially if you were dealing
with version control you had to worry
about putting your script tags all in
the right order and basically as code
bases we're getting more complex we
needed a way to manage them better so
let us set foot into the next era
do-it-yourself modules and in this
second phase of JavaScript history not
all of the problems from the pre module
era were going to go away right off the
bat but we'll start to see some of them
being addressed particularly the problem
of global variables because that was an
immediate concern so this insight about
needing to limit global variables
actually spurred a ton of innovation
with an improvisation really with what
was possible within the constraints and
flexibilities of the JavaScript language
and this was really an era of
transformation for the web we're really
moving away from the geo cities model of
static websites we're moving toward more
interactivity and Ajax requests were
becoming more of a norm during this
period jQuery hit the scene during this
time and the web was really starting to
grow up a little bit from websites to
apps and so let's just keep that in mind
as we start to look at some of the ways
that people addressed the shortcomings
of living in a world without modules
we'll pick up the story where we left
off with our friends at Yahoo had who
had just declared that global variables
are evil and their answer to this
problem of global variables was actually
just a restrict them let's let's stick
with a single object with godlike status
the Yahoo object and the aim of the
Yahoo global object was literally to
contain all of Yahoo their state their
and all of their web state and being in
all caps you can tell that it was very
important it was the global so if you
wanted to do anything you would say
Yahoo dot util Dom dot get or whatever
it might have been you were somehow
crawling through this object tree to
find find what you wanted and jQuery
might be a more familiar example you
might remember having to have the jQuery
object in available in global but as as
much as this approach was touted as
great practice there were definitely
downsides to it too so it was still
relying on a global variable a variable
a single one that could have been
rewritten with a single line of code and
then poof potentially everything could
be gone there was still no code
reusability and really no help with
dependency management or versioning but
you were starting to mitigate some of
the risks of just having free-range
global variables so the basic structure
of the namespace approach looks kind of
like this we've got an object literal
here and we've got some properties on it
some data some functionality and we can
assign those additional properties
additional data while we're declaring
that namespace object or after the fact
with our handy-dandy dot notation and
let's look at another approach that
started coming up in this area era and
that's the module pattern and the
essence of the module pattern is being
able to use an immediately invoked
function expression with the power of
closure so the power of closure is that
it would shield private variables from
being accessed outside of that function
scope and as most of you know closure is
what allows us to have access to the
variable variable environment a function
of a function even after we've exited
its scope so you'll continue to see this
pattern as we move along that function
scoping is how we're going to start to
get these boundaries and start to
collect our variables in places where we
can kind of protect them and not have
them hanging loose everywhere
control yourself JavaScript so here's a
rather simple example of the module
pattern in practice so this my
do-it-yourself module we're assigning to
it the return value of this if e and in
that if e we've got in our closure
scopes and private variables and then
we've got our exposed functions that are
returned via an object with the
increment in print properties and so as
one might expect you can call the print
function and find out what your counter
variables value is at any point you can
call the increment function increment
your counter if you printed it again its
value is 1 but you cannot access that
counter directly that is the important
thing thanks to our function scoping it
is it has lived it is gone you can't
touch it
and here's another popular
implementation from back in the day also
the module pattern just a flavor of it
called the revealing module pattern
which is almost exactly the same but in
this case both our public and private
variables are declared outside of the
return statement so pretty much
everything all of our variables are
being defined in closure scope and we're
selectively revealing what we want to
and I my understanding is that this
revealing module pattern was mostly just
readable it was easy to use it was easy
to work with you could work mainly
within that returned object and decide
what you wanted to have and what you
didn't want to have included you didn't
have to use this keyboard as much when
you at all really
you could simply refer to variables by
name potential disadvantages of this
approach this was actually considered by
people who were thinking about it one of
the most fragile ways of actually
implementing the module pattern you
might imagine that if you had some
public variable that you were trying to
change so you were trying to reassign it
after having declared it and suppose you
also had a private variable in here
which somehow used or depended on that
public variable well you might have a
little bit of trouble and not get what
you expect because because these
variables are defined in this function
scope what's accessible to those private
variables and to private methods is the
closure functionality is what was in
this function scope at the time at the
time this if he was invoked and so you
might basically this is just to say that
you might get some unexpected results it
wasn't wasn't the best of the module
pattern but it was out there quite a bit
in the wild
and just so we're clear namespace
namespaces in the module pattern are not
mutually exclusive approaches they often
did go hand in hand which is something
the late Doug Crockford advised and so
here we got a variation of the module
pattern that takes a namespace object as
a parameter you can also sometimes find
this out there with the dot Col function
and you're using the dot call function
and passing in the namespace object and
then you just use the this keyword
instead of having that namespace in
there as a function parameter but anyway
same kind of idea
we pass in the namespace add some data
and functionality to the namespace but
we've got privacy we've got that privacy
that that immediately invoked function
scope provides us nice - closure so
JavaScript is kind of cool okay so
that's a wrap on our quick blazing tour
through the early module era and as you
can see the tools within JavaScript did
take us a long way towards solving the
global namespace pollution problem but
we still feel like it's we still weren't
where we want it to be if he still felt
a little like a hack job we were still
dealing with this giant global god
object and we still had some problems
that remained we never got to the point
that we were able to actually swap
modules with one another module sharing
was not made any easier by this so and
related to that the copy/paste problem
with reusing functionality so even with
the module pattern we didn't really get
what we mean when we say modularity we
didn't get all of those benefits that we
wanted so that brings us to the next
phase specification so what's getting
specified here is a format a format that
modules should take so we can
consistently know and reliably know how
we're going to load the
and send them out into the world and as
in the last era we start with a
manifesto around 2009 or 2010 people
were feeling - strong emotions about
JavaScript on one hand people were very
excited about JavaScript potential as a
language and folks who were especially
working on the server side we're excited
to see that javascript could be used on
the on the server side so great
excitement on one hand great frustration
on the other frustration about the
limitations of the language and all the
things we wanted to do with it but
remember a little baby JavaScript coming
from mr. Brendan Ickes womb wasn't
really built for any of the things any
of these expectations that were piling
onto javascript so kevin dan gore
another name that I may be butchering my
respects to him wrote a blog post in
January of 2009 that was called what
server-side JavaScript needs and he
outlined a proposal that included among
other things a model system so there are
some other things that he proposed and
many of them we actually know and love
today so he talked about having a
package system for deploying and
distributing modules he talked about
having some kind of package repository
for finding and installing these
distributed modules and none of this
existed at the time this was all kind of
a pipe dream like wouldn't it be nice
wouldn't it be nice if we as a
JavaScript community had these resources
available to us he talked about cross
interpreter standard libraries also
being important
so api's that could be used across
different browsers like Dayton math
already were at that time so he was you
know wouldn't it be great if we had an
API for the file system that was
consistent across browsers anyway the
bottom line is that Dan Gore felt that
what he was describing was not actually
a technical problem it was an
organizational problem it was about
finding consent
this among the JavaScript community
bringing people together so they could
make a decision and step forward and
start building something bigger
something better together so like
adopting some a common currency or a
common language his blog post which
you're welcome to check out ultimately
led to the formation of a grassroots
group of similarly fed up developers who
called themselves eventually or commonjs
and they decided that they would start
setting some standards for JavaScript
including standardizing module loading
not too long after that note came out
just a few months later so this was May
2009 tangora wrote his blog post in
January and they created a module
implementation which has since taken the
name Commons a s but it's distinct from
that original group as we'll see that
original group didn't end up meeting all
of their goals they kind of created some
things that they didn't mean to but
anyway note had a number of competitors
at the time that were also in the
business of creating server-side
environments for JavaScript but node 1
and the CJ s the commande s
specification name stuck with that the
node implementation so that's what we
think of when we say Commons a yes today
we're talking about nodes implementation
of modules and the Commons is spec
stipulates support for module loading
via a require method and assigning
exports to this property on the module
object called module exports and this
was really designed with server
development in mind that will become
important in a few minutes
you might be working in node already but
if you're not and if you're not hanging
out in CJ s regularly we'll have a quick
look at the syntax we've got an awesome
jeaious file here and we are attaching
we are exporting as its module interface
this awesome person function that says
so-and-so is awesome I wish I had people
affirming me like that all the time and
in some other file we are using that
wonderful require method to bring in
that awesome person functionality and
that require method is going to have you
load a module and now you can have
dependencies the require function is
actually really powerful it is something
that will block notes thread of
execution module loading in node is
synchronous not a big deal actually
because on the server side you're
working typically with file systems and
your files are there already it's not a
huge tax or a huge cost to be dealing
with with synchronous module loading and
node but I'll walk through a few fun
pointers related to the require method
one thing that I learned actually this
year while working on that react project
was that node actually caches its
modules and it looks in the cache first
to see if the module has already been
created as a module instance and so the
fun Reaper could repercussions of that
are that you could potentially modify
that module after caching it and then
when you're working with that same
module again it might have some
additional properties that you might
have assigned to it it may have it it
can change or evolve and have all of
those properties that you you give it
and then this module dot underscore load
function that's kind of under the hood
of the require method then calls this
module dot underscore compile function
and that's where the magic happens
this method creates a special require
function actually it's specific to every
module instance that's being created and
it generates a wrapper function so
remember just like with the module of
pattern where we had to scope things
scope the contents that we wanted sort
of protected in a module within a
function so that we could have that
little pile of data and functionality
and properly scoped variables same trick
here a little more sophisticated but
we're still using function scopes and
then it actually runs that wrapper
function on the spot and I think I want
to highlight here that all of this kind
of happens at once you start wherever
your entry is into your you start
wherever with whatever file you're
entering into you hit your require
statement node goes off to another file
does its thing doesn't move on until it
comes back and finishes its trail of
dependency unwinding so anyway so in
case you're curious here's what the
wrapper function roughly looks like I
just grabbed this from the node docks
and github they've got a nice a nice
little readme type page on modules and
yeah kind of made this point already but
function scoping is a powerful tool in
JavaScript
nothing outlives the execution of that
wrapper function except what's actually
exported from that module and that's yep
so that function will that wrapper
function will assign whatever is being
exported to that file to the module dot
exports and off you go you have whatever
you wanted that was exported from that
file file name and durnais Mar just
convenience variables so you don't have
to type out the whole path and directory
that's nice that node did that for us
so there are of course options for using
the commonjs module format on the
browser
many of us are again doing some kind of
translation to whatever newfangled
JavaScript code we're using so that we
have continued compatibility anyway so
CJ s wanders me on the server every now
and again if we wanted to we can use
those require methods if we want to so
uh remember our friends at Commons is
like the group of fed-up developers not
the not the specification so in a
strange plot twist even though they were
really talking about JavaScript for the
server side they didn't succeed in
offering any kind of usable spec for the
server side but they did create one for
the client called asynchronous module
definition or AMD quick look at the
syntax there this define method takes as
its first parameter this array of
dependencies and then it has this
function that it's going to fire off
once those dependencies have been loaded
true to its method it is asynchronous it
is better suited to the browser and
requirejs is one of the more popular
libraries folks are using with AMD and
then UMD the universal module definition
which I heard a developer or I read that
a developer was joking that when you try
to please everybody no one leaves happy
so this was an attempt to support both
the CJ a spec and the AMD spec and with
this Hulk of boilerplate as you might
imagine it never really caught on no one
wants to do that no one wants to do that
so so rest in peace um D I'm sure there
are people or I'm sure there are some
code bases that are using it
anyway so we may say that specifications
really flourished in the early part of
this decade but while they were a
wonderful thing and while there was a
lot of innovation and a lot of effort to
come up with specifications that we all
use it is possible to have too much of a
good thing
check Glowacki man all these names are
hard he was a member of embers core team
and he wrote in 2014 that unless all
dependencies used the same module format
dependency tree of depth greater than 1
is so painful nobody does it nobody
agrees on a solution to this problem we
are all [ __ ]
so anyway specification hell and finally
that brings us to the last part of our
tour where are we now
well I really wish I could tie up this
presentation in a nice bow but the fact
is that we're still kind of in the
awkward teenager phase of Java
JavaScript really finding its adulthood
and finding oh it it's way of living up
to the expectations we put on it we've
seen a lot of far from ideal solutions
but we finally do have a built-in module
system and that's a huge leap forward in
the development of a language that was
never supposed to come this far so think
about where we started
yes modules actually are supported by
all major browsers as of this year I
think it was last month actually that
Firefox just released their es modules
compatible version and there's a lot of
talk about how ES modules are
asynchronous that's not exactly right
really depends on the loader well we can
talk a little bit about that but I think
that's probably beyond the scope of what
we can talk about tonight but other cool
cool things include support for cyclic
depend
see so those are dependencies that
either direct depend on each other
directly or with a few degrees of
separation in between um not going to go
too deep under the hood with es modules
today but let's at least look at this
beautiful and consistent and concise
syntax that it offers us we've got to
export types on the Left we can have
default exports some of this may be
review for those of you who are doing
this on a daily basis we can have named
exports so here I've got a default
export coming from a message that J s
file I've got three little trivial
arithmetic functions that are coming
from a library J s file and then their
corresponding import methods so we can
import whatever we export it as a
default export using the import
statement like so with the word from
when we're dealing with a file that has
multiple names exports then we have the
option of importing all of them we can
even name give a name as to the
containing object so importing all of
these little functions is live or I
guess I could have called arithmetic or
something from libe j s we can
selectively decide which parts of the
interface that we want to bring in using
I guess this is kind of it's not exactly
yes that's kind of object this D
structuring um yeah I would call that
object this restructuring cool and in
the browser we still have our trusty old
script tag that has survived many years
of JavaScript but now we have a new
special attribute called type that we
can call type and we can assign it
module to let the browser know this is
not regular JavaScript that you're going
to be parsing you're going to be looking
at a module file and that has to be
handled differently
so javascript can begin its process of
module loading build building out a
dependency tree and all of that we also
have a fallback for older browsers so
when you have the no module attribute
this is going to be ignored by those
modern browsers that are using modules
natively the no module attribute says
ignore me to those browsers but if you
are not in one of those browsers if
you're in an older browser
you've got your trusty bundled regular
javascript file in all of its global
variable glory one of the conflicts the
one of the current issues and JavaScript
is that while most browsers are up to
speed with yes modules node is not and
you might be asking yourself why node
and es modules can't just get along well
the implementation actually is pending I
was able to play around with it a little
bit and just make sure you have the most
current version of node and just use the
I think it's called experimental modules
flag or something experimental something
flag and you can absolutely play with
them in node but really what's going on
is that yes modules in common jas
modules these are really different
specifications so when I was talking
about node earlier doing the synchronous
loading and execution of of those
wrapper functions that was creating with
require that's a really different
approach to modules than es modules it's
just they they don't play nicely
together they are two different concepts
of modules so one of the things that's
caused a lot of contention is the dot
MJS I think it's modular javascript file
extension which is basically two node
what the type equals module attribute on
the script tag was to the browser so
this dot MJS file extensions that says
to note hey you're about to parse and
yes modules an es module file some
people have called it the michael
jacksons
script file extension anyway as I said I
wish I could just wrap this up in a tidy
bow but there are still a lot of
questions about what the future is going
to look like there's a lot of thought
that es modules in HTTP 2 will be very
complementary to each other with the
possibility of server push and being
able to sort of chunk out bits of bits
of code quickly on demand and yeah I
think we have yet to see what's to come
and we're kind of in an exciting phase
in the life the not so long life of
JavaScript I think it must be and it's
I'm terrible at arithmetic it's a twenty
third year it's going into its
twenty-third year just it's young
adulthood and we all get to be a part of
that and maybe at the end of that we
will get to the promised land
thank you
[Applause]